Below is a Python implementation of a reducer for
our word count problem. Let's walk through this reducer line
by line and discuss what it's doing. First, we set
initial values for word_count and old_key to 0 and None
respectively. We take in our data which you'll recall
will be a bunch of key value pairs separated by
a tab. If we have strange row with more or
less than a key and a value, i.e., the length
of the data array is not equal to, we'll
just continue on to the next row. All of these
lines down here are essentially summing up the count
for every single key. We continue through all the key
value pairs for a particular key until we notice
that we're on to a new key. Once this happens,
we print out the key and its final word count.
We then set word count equal to 0 once again.
You'll note that this implementation will not emit a key
value pair for our final key. Because of that, we have
to include this final bit of code down here. So
if old key is not equal to none, let's print out
one final key value paie. So, say that we ran
this reducer on all of the intermediate key value pairs our
mapper in the previous slide produced. We would go through
all key value pairs with the key hello. There's only one,
so we emit hello, 1. There are however, 2 key value
pairs with the key my. So we would emit the final key value pair,
my 2 for this key and so on. So now if
we use the mapper and reducer we just wrote
on a more significant example, say the text of
Alice in Wonderland, we can check that it works
and ensure that it produces the same type of result
as the Python script that you wrote earlier in this lesson.
We're going to simulate running this map reduced job by just
running these scripts locally, using Python. Note this isn't a real
map reduced deployment, we're only running this on one computer. If
we run the script, we see that we have an output
where we have all of the words that appear in Alice
in Wonderland and the number of times that each of those
words occurs. Note that all of the words are lowercase and
are stripped of all punctuation.